hello
I would like to welcome you all to the
next presentation in the behavior and
cognition track of the bio conference uh
Neuroscience meeting today
my name is David Kennedy I'm at the
University of Massachusetts Medical
School uh I co-direct the Child and
Adolescent neurodevelopment initiative
with Dr Gene Frazier who is head of
child psychiatry there and I run our
division of neuroinformatics I'll be
speaking today on a number of topics
related to big uh science Big Data
analysis in behavior and cognition and
particularly look at the neural Imaging
and informatics aspects and the
resources that are available for such an
endeavor
um so the first uh topic to consider
together is what is Big cognition uh big
is one of these uh you know popular
terms you know these days Big Data you
know is very popular the NIH has a new
Trans uh disciplinary efforts in big
data to knowledge uh and uh big data is
you know there's new journals and big
data so big data is sweeping you know
the the industry
um so when it comes to sort of cognitive
science and Behavioral Science you know
what types of things are big
um well to some extent one of my
simplistic visions of what big data is
nowadays is anything that's an order of
magnitude larger than when I was a
graduate student you know to me you know
counts as a big data if when I was a
graduate student a study was done with
20 subjects and nowadays you know it's
200 or even 2000 is the appropriate
number of subjects but we've moved into
the the Big Data era if an MRI scan when
I was uh in graduate school you know is
uh was you know six megabytes and now a
MRI session is you know 200 gigabytes
well we've moved into the Big Data era
for our particular domain uh in the when
I was a graduate student uh cellular
images electron microscopy you know
would be for a cell would be a few
hundred you know megabytes and now the
high resolution you know full you know
reconstructions of you know cells and
electron microscopy is you know
terabytes of data
so a lot of the domains now uh all have
to face with their own version you know
of Big Data uh in you know cognition and
neural Imaging aspects of cognitions you
know we are now you know doing you know
much larger Acquisitions you know per
each of our subjects and uh many more of
these subjects our analysis is becoming
more automated and we're deriving more
information from each of our subjects
and uh we need to manage and control you
know all that information
uh so one of the other aspects of big
data is our own data is getting large
but also
data sharing is beginning to happen so
not only do we have to worry about our
own data we have to worry about other
people's you know data and how do we
relate our data to their data how do we
pool those data how do we you know infer
you know higher order information from
the multiple data sources that are at
our disposal
so the good news of course is data
sharing is happening there is a special
in the neural Imaging communities
there's a lot of data sharings going on
that we'll look into a little bit more
uh further in this discussion
um things in a large part to NIH
mandates for data sharing and publisher
mandates for data sharing uh the
scientists you know perhaps somewhat
begrudgingly you know is uh moving into
the data sharing uh era as the data
becomes available uh there are many
types of data thus there are many
different types of uh sources where that
data can be shared and these sources are
getting large and they're very
distributed depending what type of data
you're looking for it could be in any of
many different locations
the other aspect uh and rationale for a
lot of the you know big data and Big
Data sharing you know that's going on is
a you know a sort of a backlash against
you know sort of smaller end studies and
small numbers of subjects uh that you
know may be perceived to be underpowered
and uh often in many domains you know
there's not always you know complete
complete replication or easily
replication of different findings uh so
again picking on neuroimaging a bit and
in certain uh communities you know many
different papers might say you know the
white matter is Big the white matter
small the white matter is you know no
different between Patient Group acts and
Patient Group y and if each of the
studies are small-ish and there's a lot
of variability in subject selections uh
there's just more ambiguity about what
the right answer is to learn these
topics so again to help uh you're not
prohibit you know small local studies
from happening but also begin to be able
to recover uh larger ends and larger
Powers through the ability to do data
sharing and uh cool data together is
important across all the different uh
disciplines
uh and again one can think a little bit
back to the uh
uh evolution of uh genetic analysis uh
again in the old days it used to be okay
to do your large you know genetic G was
you know study but nowadays you have to
do your study and you know replicate
that in a couple other you know Big Data
sources before you can uh publish that
so while the neuroimaging the cognitive
and behavioral uh communities aren't
quite near to that point yet uh I think
that's a good uh concept you know to
keep in mind that again as we do our
studies you know we need to look to the
opportunities to see replications in the
other shared data of each of our binders
um
so as the approach to larger data
sharing and larger Big Data
approaches
um begin to evolve the tools and uh
resources you know that we as you know
cognitive neuroscientists or David all
neuroscientists or neuroscientists in
general there's an evolving set of tools
you know that is uh changing you know to
meet this in a big shared integrated
landscape and so again much of my talk
today will be looking at some of those
tools and resources that are available
to navigate this landscape
foreign
so just as a brief overview of what
we'll uh talk about over the next 40 45
minutes or so uh we'll look at you know
how do we find you know these various uh
resources resources you know there's
very Broad in this context it can be
data it can be software it can be other
types of things once we've found these
resources you know what we do with these
resources how do we use them uh often if
they are data resources we have issues
about you know how to do you know data
analysis with those uh and so it's
computational topics that that raises
for us uh so often you know we
traditionally will bring these you know
to our own ground you know computers to
the computers that are in our own local
you know controller our own local
institutions and that's fine but again
emerging Technologies for cloud-based
you know computational environments you
know is is coming along and so we need
to keep uh you know abreast of the uh
the developments in that so that we know
the right resources for our various
computational needs
and then we'll spend a lasting a few
minutes of the presentation looking at a
couple case studies couple examples you
know drawn from more real world types of
examples
so I've uh already suggested that there
are many many you know resources out
there and again many resources of
different types and many resources
housed you know in different uh
environments in different locations uh
so the neuroscientists the cognitive
neuroscientists you know needs you know
techniques to find you know the
resources that are available uh for
whatever particular uh situation you
know they need to to deal with so let's
look at some of the the options for
finding resources well let's first you
know think about what you know just the
examples of what that breadth of
resources are you know that are
available and so again in in slides I'm
not going to be able to show you every
resource you know known to humankind out
there but I pick a couple examples of
resources that uh you know they you know
they're important and famous and they
also contain the information some of the
information that one wants to keep track
of
so thinking about
derived data and uh so not worrying
about you know the raw data yet often
when people do experiments and do their
analyzes they end up with results that
you know become the Hallmarks of their
Publications but the Publications and
the conclusions from those Publications
are often drawn upon specific uh
analytic results
uh so we think about functional MRI for
example uh much of the you know
processing and you know Endeavor in a
function MRI experiment is to derive you
know Foci of activations or locations in
the brain where something about the
blood flow or the you know bold you know
signal is changing uh in response to
some sort of you know changes in the
challenge that the subject is being
faced with
so over the you know two decades of
functional MRI research and you know
thousands and thousands of papers you
know um hundreds of thousands of these
spots so these Flow side of activation
you know have been identified and
published and uh uh
put into the public domain via the the
scientific research Enterprise
uh so back when the literature was small
and you know 10 or 20 papers you know
researcher you know could hold on to
that information you know all in their
head and understand what the community
was telling them about you know the
functional MRI of a particular topic but
as you know again the literature and the
number of
papers that talk about different
activation studies you know explodes you
know you need in computational ways of
managing you know this derived
information
so there's a many uh resources that have
been developed to help the investigator
manage this information uh I list you
know three of them or four of them here
the brain mapa database a very famous
and one of the oldest of them that again
is a database of the fociative
activation as published in the
literature so that one can integrate the
experiments conditions the uh the tasks
the other properties of experiments and
compare and contrast them amongst the
different Publications
sums DB uh also came along more recently
but again has a very similar challenge
to get all the foci of activation or
foci of volumetric uh you know phrase
Freight matter density differences and
managing this Foci in a particular
common you know coordinate system and
then agreed with the neurosynth are
additional resources that again given a
location in space you can report you
know what you've seen there and then
query uh the the literature so to speak
as to what other people have seen
anything there and the types of
characteristics uh that are you know
of those particular locations so even
just within a small you know concept one
piece are the types of cognitive uh data
you know portfolio you know the full
size activation there are many different
resources that can houses this
information and and uh you know
different ways that the investigator you
know needs to have you know in order to
accessing all this information
uh and again full slave activation is
just one of you know many different
derived uh entities that come from you
know neural Imaging data and then
there's other data sources as well but
within our neural Imaging near
literature often people will go out and
make you know volumetric calculations of
different brain structures and so again
thousands of Publications talk about the
brain volumes of this that the other
structure in this patient population in
that patient population so again we need
techniques to uh to house you know that
you know derive you know data sources so
that one can not have to remember all
that and be able to integrate and
compare across those different uh
Publications and so the internet brain
volume database ibbd is one of those
types of resources neuroanatomy uh and
just the textual uh referencing of a
neuroanatomic in relationship neurotem
neuroanatomic uh Concepts and
relationships to uh different
Publications you know is fairly frequent
so a recipe back from the Austin Texas
group I've created Pub green which
generates uh relationships between
Publications and brain anatomy
connectivity is very important I just
saw a nice presentation on the humans
necton project uh you know a few hours
ago but again lots of connectivity
measurements are being made in humans
and in the macaque and they need
ways to aggregate that information
across the different uh Publications you
know that come out Coco Mac is a
uh classic uh you know connectivity
database for the connections as observed
in the macaque and then connect them
with the and other newer connect Dome
databases you know coming along to
aggregate the information across those
in addition to derived data itself there
are derived Concepts so again uh
thinking about the cognitive Atlas uh
and other
resource that helps tie together you
know the higher order Concepts that have
been uh developed so Concepts like what
do different brain you know regions do
what types of uh behavioral you know
tasks you know are you know what types
of domains you know do they do they tax
and how do we have set up relationships
between multiple different types of
working memory tasks Etc so we need to
uh be able to integrate you know these
higher level Concepts as well as the
lower level concepts of uh extracted
metadata from the Imaging data itself
speaking of Imaging data that also you
know needs to be shared uh and made
available and lots of data is you know
currently available uh I divide you know
again this is just the tip of the
iceberg of many many different resources
that help investigators find and share
data I divide these sort of into two
different classes of sharing initiatives
one of which the top you know three
listed here are sort of required sharing
initiatives and sort of required in that
you know to participate in the
Alzheimer's disease neural Imaging
initiative you know part of your mandate
to participate in that was to you know
share the data within that Consortium
and a good bit of funding you know in
those initiatives you know were made
available to make the sharing happen for
that particular group and I just pick
you know sort of three random uh cases
of you know many other ones that could
be available uh paying the Pediatric
Imaging or cognition and genetics
resource you know 1400 typically
developing kids again that was mandated
to share and was given them money to to
help you know make that sharing uh
happen
so in contrast to that I also like to
point out some of the Grassroots methods
you know people who are you know sharing
data not because they had to and part of
their contract to do that but because
they want to and because it's sort of
the right thing to do in many ways and a
lot of this you know comes from the
housing functional connect domes
consortia of investigators spearheaded
by you know Mike Millum and Javier
Castellanos at uh NYU and Nathan Klein
Institute uh not only so they were again
spearheaded and you know really took an
aggressive leadership role and you know
proactively making you know resting
state functional connect Dome economic
data available uh
for the world and it turns out that you
know so 1400 you know subjects you know
were shared from you know 20 you know
some different uh institutions and
really laid the ground and it was a
typical you know young children through
old age and again really made a great
resource of you know resting state data
available to the community and a lot of
effort could go into you know exactly
how do you share and pool you know data
of that type and it turns out the
resting state data is you know fairly
well integrable with the appropriate
analytic techniques that you can
actually succeed at you know getting
larger Power by the sharing of that
resting state data in typical subjects
and that was followed up with you know
similar you know consortiums spearheaded
by Michael and his teams uh following up
in resting state with ADHD uh children
the ADHD 200 project and then more
recently the autism brain Imaging data
exchange or abide for autism investing
State data and again these are not
people who are sharing because they had
to these are people who are sharing
because they want to and use their
different available resources to make
that available
and again I hate to put anything up here
in some sense because there are many
many others it's just sort of you know
ones that come to mind
so
while lots of data is being made
available there are for the investigator
who does want to share data there is a
number of you know sort of resources for
you know participating in public data
sharing that one can can uh
access uh I'll speak more at greater
length uh the Nitric the neural Imaging
informatics tools and resources
Clearinghouse image Repository
um it's one of these public resources uh
that hasn't functional connect bones the
ADHD to under divide thing in many uh
the publicly available data sets are
made available through that resource so
if one wants to share data and wants to
contract Nitric they can help you uh
work on data sharing plan for that data
Nitric is built off a core
infrastructure it's called xmap
extensible neuroanatomic archive toolkit
spearheaded by Dan Marcus on Washington
University in St Louis
and they run xnet Central which is
another place where Oasis the Open
Access structural Imaging and you know
aging you know lives
one can utilize the accident Central
resource to share data coins from New
Mexico's mind research
Network in New Mexico makes data
available it also has the by data and
other data sets as well we have contact
uh you know them and that'll help you do
that the Lani the laboratory neural
Imaging and now at the University of
Southern California their image data
archive posts you know some very large
and major data sets
um
such as you know the adenine the
Alzheimer's disease no Imaging
initiative and and others uh and so
again that's a resource that's available
to keep in contact you know that
provider and they'll work out I'm ready
to share your data
there's other more uh specifically uh
domain uh specific silos that are uh uh
occurring as well and so one that we'll
talk more about later is endar the
National Database for autism research
which hosts a lot of Imaging data plus
all the other you know behavioral and
cognitive and you know genetic and all
the information you know that's being
collected in nih-funded studies of
autism who are being mandated to to
share their information community and
our database and they also host the NIH
pediatric database as well neuromjink
database as well and so again any effort
that's going on in in autism uh calling
up you know danmark
down hall and you know his team and I'm
more than happy to help you figure out
how to share your information through
that resource and again as with all
these lists you know these are just the
tip of the iceberg of of many resources
that are available
so again for the person who wants you
know to share the raw data the person
who wants to share their derived data uh
the pile of of resources that are
available uh is becoming quite rich and
again the investigator then has to
figure out how to deal with and comply
with these different data sharing types
of opportunities
it's also that me beholden upon the data
sharing providers and to try to meet the
investigators halfway and make that easy
enough and uh not to burden something to
do to take advantage of the Goodwills
and wishes you know to share the data as
well
so again the blessing and the curse uh
with lots of you know resources you know
being shared uh there is then the
problem you know more and more problems
you know from the again end user's point
of view of how do you you know find the
information that is relevant so the
proliferation information sources means
we need some sort of aggregation
environment some way to you know pull
information from multiple sources uh so
that you investigate don't necessarily
have to know all you know yourself you
know what all the Imaging uh available
resources are if you're an aggregator
knows that then you go and ask your
query and your aggregator can uh pull
information from multiple resources in
order to deliver that answer to you the
extensibility of you know you doing that
you know one resource at a time is just
not going to to work so we need these
aggregators
we'll talk about
two aggregators you know for a little
bit you know now uh first of which is
the Neuroscience information framework
or nif uh run by Marianne Martone and
colleagues at University of San Diego uh
and also one I'm closely involved with
the neural Imaging informatics tools and
resources Clearinghouse or Nitric both
of these initiatives are NIH blueprint
funded initiatives and uh have been
around for you know eight or nine years
uh in these cases and again have
slightly different mandates to provide
different types of information and
aggregation you know to the community
um so jumping right into nif the Mandate
of myth is really quite broad you know
every resource sort of known to you know
humankind that is related to
Neuroscience
um you know is sort of in the purview of
oops
reading some private chat here and if
someone has to tell me something I'm
sure they will okay so I'm just going to
keep sliding along here
um
so nifs purview is sort of all of
Neuroscience uh and so being able to
Aggregate and identify all the different
resources and you know provide
information about those you know to the
user and a coherent and organized in
fashion
um so I'm again just using nif and
autism as an example just to dig into
that database in a little more specific
way
nif you know is responsible for you know
trying to find anything with data you
know that's related to autism any uh
literature you know that's related to
your query any uh resources you know the
registry of resources and funding
mechanisms any you know web presences
that are related to that query as well
and uh
you know present you know resources to
you that way and so this is just a quick
you know look at the um the resources
and resource registry you know return on
the query for resources that have
something to do with autism and there's
you know 90 some you know resources
registered with uh nif that are related
and autism research resource Autism
Speaks tissue program Etc et cetera are
all you know resources that are
dedicated to or have some you know link
to the to that particular query
uh so moving along
um in addition to you know so looking at
a different you know portion of this
query looking at the data not this
autism query it returns you know again
there's a 127 000 you know records of
you know that have been annotated to
have some sort of data representation uh
that have to do with autism uh data
sources and again top on this list is
you know the autism DB and a database of
animal models you know used in autism
research uh the internet brain volume
database has lapse and brain volumes uh
that you know come from uh patient
populations you know that met that
keyword
et cetera et cetera so then there's you
know if you know tries to identify
sources and categorize those sources and
uh and make you know the elements of
those sources available that are
relevant to your particular type of
query there's also other
types of hierarchy you know that can be
done to try to Widow that window down
your results to the appropriate types of
things if you're looking for a cell
related information we can cut down to
the data resources related to cells you
know here if you're looking for function
or genes or gross anatomy or molecular
information etc etc you know they try to
expose and within an ontology if they
framework you know to expose these data
sources so that the end user can
navigate down to the particular type of
information they want and
identify those resources
so that's a nif and its mandate is a
quite broad
um so the other sort of contrasting but
complementary uh resource is nitric
General Imaging informatics tools and
resources uh Clearinghouse uh it makes
uh available you know information about
resources the specific set of resources
that are specifically related to
structural and functional and you know
neural Imaging uh originally and neural
Imaging broadly now to include Meg EEG
Optical Imaging uh and other
neuroscience and neuro clinical
neuroinformatics tools you know that
relate to your use of you know neural
Imaging data
so it has a much narrower scope than
myth and it has you know but a similar
you know need to first you know
categorize all the different resources
you know that are pertinent to that
particular topic
and so this is the front this slide here
shows you the front page of Nitric at
nitric.org
and you know some of the information you
know that's present on that front page
is sort of Click you know jumped into
the database of resources by domain it
could be MRI or CT or pet or you know
Optical tomography Etc you can Browse by
different software functionalities
uh you know software that does image
segmentation or motion correction Etc
you can Browse by
data resources Define data you know
that's relevant you know to whatever
type of query you do and you can Browse
by diagnostic types of uh characters
characteristics as well
there's other sort of featured tools and
there's you know General Community
Information there is you know sort of
recent uh updates you know to the
content of the site and there's some
news you know that comes out to again
try to keep the community engaged and
relevant to your day-to-day neural
Imaging life span
uh so jumping in you know this is a
result of a query on that site for
volumetric analyzes so a bunch of
different tools were identified you know
that have you know claimed you need to
be related to volumetric analysis and so
you can you know delve into here find
those different resources you can we
know that search down by saying yes what
specific operating system you want you
know the tools to work on what data
types you have what particular licensing
you might want you know to have uh so
all those are ways to reduce down all
the different resources that come back
to you to the ones that are particularly
relevant to your own particular needs
each resource themselves you have the
sort of standard uh front page for that
resource this is a program called itk
Snap that does you know segmentation and
image analysis of various sorts the
metric you know home page for itk snap
it's important to note that all this
content you know comes actually from the
resource provider themselves so itksnap
is providing this information not some
Metric person describing i2k snap for
you but in this um particular you know
project you are one click away from the
other documentation about that resource
the one click away from downloading you
know that resource you're one click away
from you know getting to that projects
in your home page one click away from uh
getting news and you know other you know
helpful you know types of things about
that
Nitric supports a community ratings and
reviews you know types of options so
that uh you know as people find tools
they like that install well that do
their jobs well it can help you know
give them a you know plus one you know
type of uh information
you can also see some of the activity
you know that is going on in the
resource the number of downloads number
of Publications and other uh features of
the resource the nice thing about a
Nitric you know home page for each
project though is that they're identical
so while the websites of you know 20
different uh software packages will
present you know very similar
information to this perhaps but in a
quite you know idiosyncratic way to the
ways that you know the developers you
know we're interested in the Nitric home
page for each project you know can point
to that same information but is you know
always in the same place so you always
know where to get to downloads you
always know where to get the
documentation you always know where the
ratings and reviews will be so it
homogenizes it and just makes it much
more easier for uh individuals to uh to
navigate you know around the different
content
so again running that similar query that
I did in myth on Nitric to find
different resources within uh Nitric
that are related to autism again we find
some of these similar types of resources
but again presented in the Nitric way in
which case the downloads the ratings and
reviews the uh
pointers to the documentation point just
to Publications Etc Are All Made
available in that standard framework so
nitric has a little narrower scope than
uh nif and it goes a little deeper into
each of the resources but but they work
together and share information and uh
you know sort of make a a cohesive you
know uh pair of resources to new
resource discovery
so that's ways to find easy you know
ways to find software and websites and
uh you know sort of community forums and
hardware and button boxes and you know
assessment batteries Etc
finding Imaging data itself is a little
bit different so uh where there might be
you know 20 different softwares to do
image segmentation uh there will be
ultimately you know thousands and
thousands of different images you know
that might be relevant to a particular
query or that you might be uh looking
for for particular Imaging you know data
so the nature you know that query you
know it's a little bit different
so we need to consider that a little bit
uh more
so one of the second uh main
functionalities you know that Nitric uh
developed was the Nitric image
repository now so again the idea here is
while in a regular project you know I
could share data with you just by you
know putting a file you know of data out
there and you have a tar file an archive
file of you know 100 subjects and just
make that file there give you the
demographics you can download that and
you know good luck at unpacking that and
finding the particular subjects you know
that you want
um so uh more convenient to the end user
opportunity is to really do an image
database where you know data are you
know searchable and you know uh specific
you know cohorts of subjects you know
can be identified
so nitric uh uses is you know the Nitric
image repository is built upon and again
I mentioned the xmat uh image image
archive from the toolkit from washu uh
but in a way that you know Nitric uh
image repository projects are tightly
tied with their uh
uh Nitric you know projects themselves
so the Nitric project you know the
initial resource project you can have
users and manage their uh accessibility
you know to the projects and then
there's when enabled a link to the image
repository that you know gets you to
that particular projects instead of data
and you know the project itself you can
manage you know your access is it
publicly accessible is it privately
accessible do you have to register and
what kind of uh authentication do people
need in order to qualify for access to
to your Prego data project
so Nitric resources that have the image
repository enabled have this little in
the repository link you go to that and
you jump into the xnat uh image
repository and in this particular case
you need a thousand functional connect
phones has
some large number of uh you know
subjects there you know a couple 2000 or
whatever it is I can't read it on the
screen but you uh end up you know being
able to access each of those particular
subjects you can click on one of those
subjects and you'd see that you know
that particular subject you know has a
particular you know age and particular
gender uh has pretty good diagnosis and
has some number of data sets that are
available in this case two structural
data sets and a wrestling State data set
and dig further into those data sets you
can see the parameters the field
strengths you know the repetition times
the voxel sizes and other features of
those those Imaging that's available to
you so you can drill down and find
different data sets of interest but more
importantly you can query within
specific projects to find the subsets of
that data in this case I did a query
within the Thousand functional connect
domes data set for males between 40 and
50 years old and there's 38 different
subjects you know they're identified so
you can access you know these you know
Central X you can see some information
about the type of data that's available
and If that's you know a query that
generated data that you want there's a
download link you know to download that
data right to your own desktops or for
your own use
more importantly though is since Nitric
itself hosts many image projects you can
actually search across all of those
projects in this case I did a query
across all the different projects uh for
males between uh you know 10 and 15
years old and we identified you know 980
you know different subjects you know
that are you know within that Nitric
confines structural Imaging functional
Imaging diffusion Imaging many different
uh sources of that data some come from
the autism brain data exchange some come
from ADHD project some come from the
candy share project Etc so again this is
a way that when the data is under a
homogeneous system you know queries you
know for particular characteristics that
can be done this could again be further
widowed down to different field
strengths different uh working with the
resting state data different uh common
uh TRS et cetera Etc uh can be used to
Widow down just to the particular sets
of data that you want much more
efficient by doing that from a database
query than downloading all of that data
and then through those Define the subset
of data that you wanted
okay so now what uh you know I found
some really cool software from the
Nitric resource registry you know free
Surfer made something is very popular
and does lots of anatomic segmentations
and I found a bunch of data I found 980
you know you know kids there in that uh
last query that I want to do a analysis
of you know kids you know I'm young and
you know sort of the age you know
development of different brain
structures across that age group
well great I found 980 subjects and I
found a piece of software that you know
takes about you know 24 hours you know
per uh subject to run uh do the math and
that's a really long time
um if you you know need to do that
so your options you know the sort of
old-fashioned options is you could
download that software and hope it works
on your desktop computer and go through
the installation you know process you
can download that data and hope that you
know you have the space for that you
know 980 you know subjects you know to
to um
uh you know and you know put it on your
computers at home or in your own office
uh and then let that run and uh hope
that you don't have anything else to do
for a couple of years it might take to
uh to do that particular analysis
or maybe your lab has you know high
performance computers has you know many
many more cores or maybe your
institution has high performance
Computing so you can contact you know
your high performance Computing you know
folks and try to make sure that they can
install you know for your Surf and they
have the resources for you to to do high
performance at home
and then the last option another option
is you know using the movie available
cloud computing resources as in Amazon
and Azure uh where you can purchase or
at least or rent you know Computing uh
Power as necessary uh but to do analysis
in the cloud uh that's a another type of
opportunity to do these types of
processing so let's look a little bit
more at that kind of functionality
so the Third Leg of the Nitric
set of services is signature
computational uh environment
it's available on the currently on the
Amazon uh web services Marketplace so
that's a public web page just search for
nitric and you'll find you know the
Nitric computational environments that
we'll talk about the next few minutes
these are standard uh systems that come
pre-configured with a bunch of you know
your favorite image processing tools uh
the finrib software Library acne free
Surfer and and many more softwares it's
built on a standard operating new system
the neuro Debian platform which makes it
easy to maintain and easy for Tool
developers to make tools that are you
know we'll install easily on it and it's
uh Dynamic and that you can turn them on
and off you know at your will and it
seems scalable in that you know you can
use you know one core or 16 cores or
cluster them together into however many
cores you know that you want
the somewhat downside of course is you
have to pay for you know that you know
computer you know use or leasing it
you're renting it uh so it's a really
different cost model you know so again a
option instead of you know writing in
your grants to buy you know five
thousand dollars worth of you know
computer at home you know you can you
know use that to lease computer time as
necessary say in the Amazon type of
system but regardless of that costing
which we'll talk more about later on
let's look at what the configuration of
these computational environments look
like
so again from the Amazon Marketplace you
know searching on Nitric you find our
two offerings one of which is the plain
old Nitric computational environment
that runs on one a couple of their
classes Amazon's classes of computers uh
that's here whoops wrong way and then
you'll also see our uh special
configurations that are necessary for
the compute cluster instances so when
you want to get to more cores uh the
class of Amazon computers that are
available are slightly different so we
had to configure a separate uh
configuration before that
once you select one of those
computational environments Amazon you
know nicely reminds you sort of what
your options are about how to you know
configure it or how much you know per
hour you know such a system is going to
cost and where you deploy it in the uh
in the cloud Amazon infrastructure you
know get selected and uh you give your
Amazon authorization and there you go
of course the um important thing with uh
computers that you rent or lease is that
you really got to be very efficient and
good about using them you're paying for
them if they're sitting there doing
nothing uh or if they're sitting there
you know working hard and so to make it
more cost effective you want them
working hard and then you know shut off
when you're when you're done with them
so again that's one of the new sort of
paradigms of how to do mostly this
cloud-based Computing is how to be
efficient in terms of getting the right
size computer getting all those cores
working hard and getting it shut off as
soon as you're done
but once you uh commission one of these
computers uh you've got a URL uh and
once you go to that URL you get the
Nitro configuration page for that
computer this is a just a web browser
onto your own you know personally rented
your computer you've set up some
you know features such as area username
and passwords and some monitoring
functionalities and you'll get set and
then you get to the you know launch page
you know for that computer which reminds
you all the different softwares that's
installed and reminds you the licensing
terms of those different softwares that
you're agreeing to and then you can
start your vmc sessions if you want to
sort of use a remote desktop you know to
the computer or you can then access it
you know as well through the remote
desktop or just through um
um you know SSH or other uh you know
intercomputer uh Communications
techniques
so you've selected a computer you run it
up uh and you you can now process on
that as as you see fit it comes
pre-installed as I mentioned within many
different softwares that are you know
commonly used and
so it's easy to get the exact same
environment and the installation hassles
if there were any I've already been
handled by someone else a tool developer
as opposed to you figuring out how to
install free stuff around this
particular configuration
and so just cute little snapshots again
reminding us of the different tools and
resources that are pre-configured on
that again it's a neurodebian base
package so again things that you didn't
happen to pre-configure on it for you
you know can be easily added yourself
and you can tell us and we will package
that into the future and release it in
the system as well
so the most important question right
away though is you know what is this
going to cost me because again I'm not I
have no idea what Amazon pricing is I
have no idea what the cost of some of my
usual analyzes you know look like so
performance and good efficient
utilization of these resources is um is
a you know important uh consideration
exactly how quickly you can get a job
done it depends on how powerful you know
the computer you know core that you
purchase is Amazon you know provides a
number of different sort of core
performance capabilities uh how many
cores do you purchase and how large a
system are you using uh how well you
utilize it and how well the software
you're using you know parallelizes you
know across cores and you know how much
data you want to do again I'll factor
into what it costs to do a particular
analysis
and so part of you know nitric's job in
this case is to help you know train and
teach you know us all what the you know
actual cost of this will be so that we
can um understand better how to uh uh
compare and contrast you know the costs
of cloud computing versus uh ground
Computing at your own local Institution
so let's uh we've worked our way through
a couple illustrative examples uh I
don't want to go into too much of the
details of this this is a particular uh
process that's necessary for diffusion
tractographic uh analysis uh it happens
to be one of the more time consuming
aspects of it the uh bed post the
Bayesian estimation of diffusion
parameters uh you know can take you know
many hours and it's one of the longest
steps in a standard diffusion processing
stream from the FSL Suite of tools uh so
running it on a particular case that on
you know uh you know 30 60 slices and
particular parameters you know shown
here and taking advantage of the fact
that the FSL software automatically you
know
uh parallelizes you know software using
some grid engine which is configured on
the Nitric computational environments uh
and we'll you know parse those out to
the cores you know as necessary so it
will take your you know one job which
you know may take 60 slices worth of uh
probabilistic estimation and turn that
into 60 jobs and split that across your
course
so just looking at the relative
performance on my own uh you know one
core of my own you know desktop Mac you
know this particular bed post example
takes you know about five hours or about
six hours to process uh so that's this
little you know line
you know here uh and depending on the
exact configuration of the Amazon you
know compute environment that you use uh
you can get something that's you know
slower than your Mac desktop and cost
you two dollars to run or you can get
something you know that's you know
faster you know than your Mac desktop
that uh you know can be done in about 20
minutes and cost you about you know
three dollars to run so it's just one
subject's worth of analysis uh but you
get it done in 20 minutes you're paying
by the hour so it's actually three
subjects you could have gotten done in
that so that runs out to about a dollar
you know per subject you know and you
have to do three subjects an hour uh if
you use you know these this particular
you know 16 core system
uh so that's just one example and so
again if you have hundreds of subjects
you can begin to calculate what the cost
will be and what the time will be so
again going back to my little example
from before that said I wanted to do
about a thousand you know cases uh and
it's about a dollar a case well then
it's going to cost me you know a
thousand dollars now again that's you
know on the one hand you seems large oh
yeah it's a thousand dollars on the
other hand you know if one you know
thinks about you know the Alternatives
you know to doing that and you know
purchasing that through your grants and
things like that as opposed to you know
purchasing computers or you know funding
the uh depreciation of your own you know
institutions high performance Computing
again there's still questions about
exactly you know how to best use uh such
uh compute you know dollars
um but the other good thing about this
same thousand dollars is I could do that
you know if I just use that 16 core
system I showed you on the other page
that takes about 20 minutes per subject
uh and to do a thousand subjects that's
going to take me 14 days and you know so
14 days is better than the year it would
have taken or 31 you know days that
would have taken on my own desktop
um
but for the same thousand dollars
instead of using one you know 16 core
computer I can use you know the star
cluster the elasticity of the Amazon
system and you know cluster together 333
of these same uh core uh components and
generate you know 5 000 cores and get
this whole job done in in one hour so
again for that you know cost uh one has
a lot of flexibility about you know how
quick and uh uh one can do that
depending on how the job you know scales
and parallelizes
oh this pricing I've done here is on
their on-demand uh pricing which is the
higher you know pricing tier uh with
other trickier thinking one can also do
spot pricing with Amazon and get you
know significantly lower you know costs
uh at the cost of some uncertainty about
exactly when they will run and when you
get you know computers to that cost so
there's a sort of upper bounds of the
cost of some of these things so again a
bed post you know costs about a dollar
you know to do
similar experiments uh on your
voxel-based morphometry of a of a
hundred subjects you know will cost you
about you know three dollars to do and
about eight hours you know to accomplish
that on a particular you know
configuration with eight quarters uh
free Surfer
um
which you know can be done you know on a
small you know One Core system in 20
hours you know will cost you two dollars
or so and again you can make that happen
faster but again that's kind of the
order of magnitude of the processing
that's available for that kind of thing
so at least that begins to develop uh
situations to figure out sort of what
the costing of these different uh
opportunities will be
so last but not least I want to get into
a couple
sort of real world use cases of this you
know in the application to both doing
sort of more comprehensive Big Data
elements of Publications and also some
processing that's begun to be done with
the computational environments on the
endar database
um without getting into too much um uh
discussion you know a lot of our current
uh processing and press thinking you
know goes towards the journal article
being the most important thing that's
what gets you your grants gets what gets
you your tenure gets in uh your
improvement in life uh and the
publication is really based on some
interpretation of you know some results
which are hand-picked you know to tell
your story which came from one
particular analysis method of many that
one could have done on a big huge you
know pile of data that uh one has so the
only thing that persists you know
currently you know is that
interpretation you know your Journal
article says you know the claudate
nucleus is big and you know correlates
with you know the uh uh behavioral
dysfunction in kids with uh
the behavioral dysregulation
um and that's what ends up in the
literature that's what people cite and
that sort of all that you know lasted
from a huge pile of data from one
particular analysis technique that you
took versus one particular set of
results that you know happened to turn
into the story you know that you uh
chose to to write about
um a lot of this big data effort is to
try to turn that upside down yes you
still get your Journal article you know
down here at the end but it's that data
which is the most uh long lasting you
know part of it especially when that's
shared uh yes you can do your particular
you know analysis uh but you know other
people you know could do you know
different types of analyzes uh making
your results available yes you have to
pick some results to write the story but
we need to make it so that all those
results that came out are available as
well so that when you come to your
interpretation and your Journal article
we don't lose you know this whole you
know
information you know that led into that
and that's you know amongst the things
it sort of drives the big side of uh big
data and big you know computation in you
know cognitive and behavioral and
neurosciences in general
so right now again it's not rocket
science you know to do any of this a lot
of the Technologies for integrating you
know data into your Publications you
know exists you know now uh looking here
and then not to read the details but a
small version of my Pub of a PubMed you
know entry from a particular paper you
know of ours uh PubMed has these link
out options you can pick on you know and
the user using different you know
techniques can make these link out team
appear for your own particular
Publications uh so this particular
publication it has a link out to a
Nitric you know project page which hosts
all that data you know that went into
that so the raw data is linkable to the
to the publication through that you know
link out there and then also the you
know the meta analysis in this
particular paper was volumetric analysis
of a bunch of different structures and a
particular patient population and that
can be linked directly to the
publication as well so again in this
particular situation by publication and
PubMed and my conclusions are here but
also your linkage to the raw data and
your linkage to the metadata you know
that associated with that can be
established so again as long as one's
willing to share their data and put them
someplace you know that's findable uh
the linkages the connections between
your Publications and your data and
metadata can be established
this is Gory details of not only the
data that was part of that publication
is available on this particular website
but lots and lots of other things about
that data can be made and that goes even
Beyond you know the analysis of that
paper and other subsequent analyzes of
that data can also all be linked
together
um so that's a good thing to do
so to finish you know quickly
um again looking into the endar database
uh the National Database brought some
research at ndar.nih.gov
uh this is part of the National
Institutes of mental health effort to
really consolidate their you know
research you know prospects in autism
under sort of a unified situation the
database itself you know hosts all sorts
of information about you know phenotypic
descriptors about genetics about you
know neural Imaging we can you know
dredge down into this and again find you
know all of our six to 12 year old you
know boys you know yields you know again
some set of sessions with some set of
you know diagnostic characteristics and
some set of uh behavioral
characteristics we can dig down into
that and you know request you know that
data once you have proper authorization
uh and so not only did I find that data
based on its Imaging the fact that it
has Imaging there's you know hundreds of
other measures and hundreds and tens of
different sites where that data came
from uh that is all available to you
once you did that query and uh you know
do that download
once you download that you can uh get a
data package that again you can run at
home you know as before or run on any
high performance consistent on cloud uh
that data lives also in the Amazon S3
simple storage uh environment so that
instead of downloading it all a little
the National Database can give you a
pointer to where that data resides and
so you don't have to even download
things when you're working in the cloud
environment and then a different
Pipeline and automated systems can also
be invoked on that so yes you can handle
that by hand but you can also use
something like the Lonnie pipeline which
is a you know workflow environment
manager to set up workflows that you
know take the cloud-based Source the S3
you know source of your ndar data
package and then do different processing
in this case a free server processing
and FSL processing and you can launch
those you know to run on your Nitric
computational environments or on you
know Lonnie's you know high performance
Computing and so again this is a way to
act access the end our data to use your
Niche computational environment and to
use a nice you know graphical interface
you know to interoperate with that
environment uh to run and control you
know a large you know analysis
so that's been done uh on the large pile
of data that's in the end our data set
uh two different types of runs have been
done one of which is a image quality
assurance you know checks uh a bunch of
different uh signal to noise contrast to
noise uh volumetrics types of
measurements have been made across that
uh structural data there's a diffusion
quality assurance and a functional
quality assurance system as well so
these have been run you know using
miniature computational environment
these results have been fed back into
the endar system so it's then become you
know queryable you know as parts of the
features of data that you select based
on you know structural properties
um
and not only has the quality assurance
been done again a common thing one might
do is run you know free Surfer or
different types of you know structural
analyzes on this data so again as you
know those get run centrally if one
wants you know that data gets put back
into endar and that becomes properties
that you can navigate against the data
so that's really where I think I'm going
to come to an end in general in summary
you know big you know cognitive um uh
Neuroscience these days is evolving to
include you know data repositories and
you know management of you know large
data uh management of workflows and
Analysis you know systems in a
reproducible fashion management to the
results
um into metadata stores so that all the
results can be retrieved and queried
against and not just what uh shows up
you know in the words of the literature
uh and then of course the interpretation
and the story written about the data
yeah we'll continue you know as it has
it's about each of these types of
information required tools and resources
to get your data into it and to
interrogate the data that is there and
so we all have to go through these new
learning curves we want to be able to
wield these things efficiently
like to thank you know the
Nitric Enterprise for uh helping uh you
know make this happen and a number of uh
you know co-investigators I have book at
UMass at uh Turner Consulting Group uh
you know in Washington that does the
core Network development uh the end of
our folks and the the Lani folks for
helping this is the pipeline in this
environment
so that leaves me a couple minutes uh
left for uh for questions
um I think I'll leave it on in this
slide for the end and I'll see if I
understand how to see if any of you out
there any questions
I see no questions yet in my
uh question of that
it was either uh oh great presentation
thank you
do I see that
so I guess that's supposed to be a
question mark not a uh exclamation point
but um so was it a great presentation
um
so again try to get a bunch of
information out there for you and again
resources to uh
be useful and again contact me or any of
the other uh resource providers to help
you
why doesn't the NIH mandate all
researchers to share their data well
they're beginning to and again I think
they've been starting you know slowly so
from 2008 or so the initial data sharing
mandate uh came out that said all grants
that are larger than 500 000 annual cost
budget you have to have a data sharing
plan
so that was a good start
um but that left a lot of openings in it
so Grant yeah most grants are smaller
than 500 000 so that kind of you know
evaded that and having a data sharing
plan uh doesn't necessarily mean it's a
good you know plan or that uh the data
is well you know shared and most
importantly there was very little teeth
in that mandate in that you could write
your plan and it wasn't a scorable
element and no one checked your data
sharing you know very well you know
afterwards uh to see if you complied
so I think the NIH is working on uh
beefing up you know those mandates and
uh there's a data sharing groups within
NIH who are working on that and also
initiatives like you know endar so
within a NIMH who you know can you know
exert some control on their autism
portfolio uh they actually do it's part
of their Contracting it's part of the
autism centers of excellence it's
probably written into virtually every
autism grant that says Thou shalt you
know share all of your data you know
like it or not so again I think slowly
but surely the mandate to share you know
is coming along
the counter to the mandate to share
though is also having resources to share
your data in so things like Nitric
things like you know these x-map
databases you know they cost money their
infrastructures you know and every
dollar you know NIH spends on
infrastructure is a dollar that's not
getting spent on uh you know solving you
know autism or solving you know bipolar
disorder or solving other things so it's
a you know it's a tricky question that
you know again mandate to share but you
know not but you know making sure that
this place is to share you know is also
important so again these are tricky
philosophical and and things that you
know are being worked out and are
improving and uh again more leases are
coming available and more ways to figure
out how to fund that and you know sort
of the data sharing tax you know make
sure that's not too high and make sure
the value for that is is worth it before
you force everyone to do it or else the
passing school
okay
it's just
two minutes uh
left I guess
and I thank everyone for uh attending it
was fun to try this uh electronic
presentation and I hope
that was interesting
share that data